Did you get a job after you got
laid off a tall man long to do such
a job went back to you married
in those days while i was
working on the bridge 1930. And did
your mates give you anything of as
a memento that no because
it was very quiet say i
was out here. I got no relations after
a year. And the wife was
the same move she had was
a proud. And it was
married. No sidney. But
church. Some pages church you know sydney
. Can you tell me do you remember what
you are where were you when the arch was
joined in the workshop when the arch which
still end. And it was in the morning.
And of course we got the tie
off. I think it was about
between ten eleven at the moon. And as
we all march out we got percent it was
a campaign to show
a little bit. And somebody couldn't
say oh it's got permission
from somewhere to at king's head on. Of
and it lock into the sydney harbour bridge.
I think that was david i know some of
the like. Well who had it done. It may have
been i wouldn't say for sure who it was
but i know i cut my daughter's got to
show them but still and she prices.
Believe some of them got sovereigns the
ones that were up there on the table
slackening they made and i couldn't tell.
I don't didn't know too much about the
outside work at all although we
tried to get out at the top and
there was no put up that there's
a bounce to staff and workers
be instant dismissal
left climbing up. Did you
climb up there. I had me
arf way up went up the top.
And that was bad enough for
out when you look down. But then the
first i think that went under the
arch was the new holland attached
. That was the first boat that when under
the arch. Do you remember any of the
other work when you work with out of the
workshop. Thompson and joe thompson
to private and the piper riveter
and three is so long that
you forget their names and
did which did you have anything to do
with any of the bosses know i know
this about us and of whose
phone and what wilson
said i think was another part and that
if you'd and you were left alone you
interfered and that. How long did you
go for lunch breaks. Oh yeah nigga
and that nourished alone for lunch. I
say i only lived just across from the
shop out
a back door just in the cone
and sam. Do you remember
any of the well you see of
course you wouldn't room with
a lunch. Therefore do you remember any
of the opening of the bridge. Yes up and
down. Certainly for the open end of the
bridge and that took crushed and that
little boys. Yes we had it good down
there. Do you remember how much you got
paid while you were on the bridge. Now
i could tell you that no i couldn't
tell you were you didn't get any hope money
anywhere because you're in the workshop
. Now we don't know how to manual
danger money or anything that stays.